welcome back let me erase what I did in
my should have done this before starting
this time take too long all right we're
in problem number six problem number six
and once again a figure that has not
been drawn to scale and do that to you
on purpose sometimes it is drawn to
scale and they say that it's not you
shouldn't assume anything all right
and they saying that this is three x
degrees they say that this is two x
degrees and they say that this is four x
degrees and the figure above three line
segments meet at a point to form three
angles what is the value of X well what
if all of these angles gonna have to add
up to well if you add this angle Plus
this angle Plus this angle what do you
do you've went all around the circle so
they have to add up to 360 degrees so
what's so two x plus four X plus three X
is going to equal 360 degrees and what's
two plus four plus 3 that's 9 X let me
see this is always where I messed up 2
plus 4 is 6 6 plus 3 is 9 9 X is equal
to 360 X is equal to that's not 360
divided by 9 equals 40 and that is
choice C problem number seven
seven positive integers XY and Z so
they're integers satisfy the equations X
to the minus 1/2 is equal to one-third X
to the minus 1/2 is equal to the
one-third Y to the Z is equal to 16 okay
those are the two equations if Z is
greater than Y so Z is greater than Y
what is the value of X plus Z this value
of x so the trick is because you say
well how do I solve for this well the
trick is that you know that these are
all integers so first of all let's do
this so X to the minus 1/2 is equal to
1/3 that means that 1 over the square
root of x right I just rewrote X to the
minus 1/2 is you know 1/2 our square
root and the negative means the inverse
so 1 over the square root of x is equal
to 1/3 or you could say the square root
of X is equal to 3 X is equal to 9 right
so that was easy we just solved this you
just have to know that a negative means
to invert and that 1/2 power same thing
as square root now why does Z equals 16
we got to come up with integers y and z
where z is greater than y that end up at
16 well the number that immediately pops
out is 2 to the 4th power to the fourth
power is equal to 16 the other option
was 4 to the second power right but 4 to
the second power wouldn't have satisfied
this because 4 is greater than 2 so the
exponent has to be greater than the base
of 2 to the fourth so and we know that
because it has to be integers so we know
that Z is equal to 4
so what's 4 plus 9 it's 13 all right X
plus Z 13 and that is choice D
next problem hey I'm on problem number 8
and let me draw what they have drawn
they have yeah I don't even know it's
useful for me to draw but I will do it
because they've done it and then they
have a semicircle so I could I could do
a semicircle something like this I could
draw it like use the circle tool like
that roughly good enough I could erase
the bottom if I wanted to but let's just
assume that we only see this top part
and they say so this is point whoops I'm
still using the line tool this point is
4 comma 0 this point is 8 comma 0 and
they say in the semicircle above the
center is at 4 comma 0 which of the
following are x-coordinates of two
points on the semicircle
whose y-coordinates are equal which of
the following are x-coordinates of two
points on the semicircle whose
y-coordinates are equal well this is it
this is an interesting question because
it's not so much math but I really just
get getting the intuition of kind of the
symmetry of the circle so it wants to
know two points on the circle where the
Y is equal so for example this point and
this point the Y is going to be equal
write it so it would be this point at
this point and similarly we could you
know we could say well this point and
this point the Y's are equal and if we
take down beat this point at this point
the key is is any of these pairs of
points have to be the exact same
distance from the center that makes
sense if we go the same distance to the
left and go up to the circle and we go
the same distance to the right and go up
to the circle they're going to intersect
the y axis at the same point so we have
to look at their choices and see which
of their pairs of choices are equal
distant from x equals 4 right equal
distance from x equals 4 so the first
choice is 1 in 6 1 is 3 less than 4 and
6 is 2 more than 4 so that doesn't work
all right a is one in six and that
doesn't work because six is much closer
to four than one is it's be this choices
one and eight well one is three away
from four right one is here
well eight is all the way here so eight
is for more than four all right three
less for more not doesn't work see two
and six this looks promising
2 is 2 less than 4 6 is 2 more than 4 so
that's like you know two less Bam's
gonna move there two more
BAM gonna be there so that's our answer
we don't even have to look at the other
ones but if you look at the other ones
you'll see that they're all different
distances away from x equals 4 the next
problem problem number 9 if P is an
integer and 3 is the remainder when okay
so let me write as p integer 3 is
remainder when
when 2p plus 7 is divided by 5 3 is the
remainder then P could be okay well we
could there's a bunch of ways you could
do it but really the simplest way the
very simplest way is to just try out the
numbers and let me ask you a question if
when you divide something by 5 if you
get a remainder 3 what is that number
gonna have to end in what's gonna end in
a 0 or 5 right because any I'm sorry
it's gonna end with a three or an eight
because if something is divisible by
five it ends with a 0 or a 5 right 5 10
15 20 25
all of these are divisible by 5 all of
and if you add 3 to any of these numbers
8 thirteen eighteen twenty three twenty
eight and so on 33 all of these numbers
are gonna have a remainder of three when
you divide by five right and then you
could also say well so any of these
numbers is gonna be the numerator any of
these numbers is gonna be the numerator
so this number any of these is gonna be
the numerator and then you can actually
if you want you could you know subtract
seven but actually we won't do that what
we could do is just try out the
different choices they give and see if
any of these choices and in a create a
number that ends in an eight or a three
so let's see choice a is 2 what is 2
times 2 plus 7 it's 4 plus 7 which is 11
it's not that one because it ends with
the one be 3 3 times 2 is 6 6 plus 7 is
13 we're done and you could try it out
if P is 3 2 times 3 is 6 plus 7 13
divided by 5
well the remainder is gonna be you know
Stu remainder 3 so it works that was it
and it's good we didn't have to waste
time figuring out CDE okay and then oh I
only have a minute left so I will wait
to do that the next problem in the next
video see you soon